yeah welcome everyone uh everybody who
is just joined the room on there is a
gift with the Jupiter notebooks the
slides everything I'm going to show you
including all the solutions and
everything is already on github
feel free to download it on some so this
will be a walkthrough tutorial so I'm
going to main mostly walk to you walk
you through what I'm doing um I'm happy
to take questions up to a certain extent
because we only have 90 minutes and with
quite some ground to cover so and then I
will encourage you just to play around
with what you just have learned about
all by yourself so there will be no
programming riddles to solve because I
don't I think it's taking too much
overhead because we want to learn a lot
today um so there's an introduction
about pandas arm who knows pandas okay
who has worked with pandas who is very
confident with pandas what are you doing
here okay welcome to um so this is a
from the background who's like a real
Python programmer who's new or who's or
by the way who's rather new to Python
alright okay but everybody who has
experience in one programming language
okay all right almost everybody is quite
confident to programming so we don't
need super programming skills to use
pandas you can basically learn the
methods of course if you know basic
Python arm or even the better your in
Python the more you can do with pandas
especially if you want to mangle the
data so um okay let's start um so I'm
Alexander ah I work with ku next week in
Mannheim we're a strategic consultancy
and we consult startups and the
middle-sized industry so mine domain
here is data science consulting um
also on the team mode for Europe - I'm
the program chair and one of the
organizers there are same for the
upcoming
PyCon de Canterville in October and they
I like to speak and teach and talk so
what are we going to talk about today
arm we're going to do an introduction to
pandas I'm going to tell you a little
bit about the pandas origin and why is
why is it there
are we going to be follow a long
tutorial so we're going to start with
like practical really basic stuff and
I'm trying to introduce you more and
more in with little depth how we can how
will panel works
how are the inner mechanics of pandas
are and how you can make use of them to
work with your data um so um to follow
along to play along with the code please
get this gift now um
it's not necessary to follow along with
this tutorial it's handy to have and and
we're going to put the short URL here so
in case you for everybody who's late or
just take a picture so can everybody
from the back
reads slide okay probably we make the
room a little bit more darker so
okay I just okay
I think that's better isn't it
okay I hope that's okay for the
recording as well
nah okay
okay Google would try to solve the light
situation it's very binary here on okay
okay um in case you have trouble of just
download the slides and the the Jupiter
notebooks if you in case you have
trouble reading it so what are you going
to do today first we're going to start
with reading and writing data all in to
read path right data in pandas write
data out of handles and pandas is many
self and Culture sleuths multi-purpose
knife for data analysis so pandas is
very happy to read almost every data
format you can think of very easily so
you can do read CSV Excel files Jason
you can even load data from the
clipboard HTML HDFS you name it now if
you want to have a full list please feel
free to go to and doctor Docs um so and
this brings us to our first slide so
this is a practical start into pandas so
the first thing is if you're new to
pandas we import pandas with import
pandas SPD it's a convention it's
you find it everywhere like everybody
uses nobody uses just like input pandas
it's always import pandas SPD and so we
reference both pd2 pandas for the rest
of our code I try spanner
hmm I think this will work okay ah so in
our data directory that's just like the
directory we have some files and this is
more like a Jupiter trick we can use
exclamation mark PWD or just like on an
Linux console and to see what's your
current working directory and another
handy thing is you can also just do an
LS to see what's in our data directory
so we see we have some sales data from
the Bluth data store data yeah from the
blue sales data on and it also includes
a generator for fake for generating fake
user data which is quite handy but so so
the first thing we're going to do is are
is just like get one of these CSV files
and read them into or pandas dataframe
and what the data frame is and all this
I'm going to cover later so just let's
imagine that let's get the 3ds into a
table and a table we can work with so
all we need to do is call the read CSV
methods and pass in file class and
that's basically it and let's explore
our data set so and
so this is what we have um what's more
so I can't matter okay this is basically
our data set um it's all burden that's
the magic of Jupiter all we need to do
is just basically print sales data to
the screen and we get this nice print of
what we have and that's basically that's
very one of the simplest things you can
do in pandas a few things you probably
already see we have an a header file in
our seriously and the header files are
automatically use this column names we
also see this thing here on the Left
which is not in the data that's called
the index we're going to talk about that
later but basically it's quite simple um
since this is a little bit too long
let's reset this that's just another
thing you can just do on the fly we can
just set an option for pandas to display
only like ten rows we want and so it's a
little bit more fun and we also get
information our data set has like a
thousand rows and seven columns so and
let's see what what do we have in sales
data let's do a little bit more Asian of
what what's the type so the type r is a
panda's data frame and dimensional array
it also has a standard length which is a
thousand and we can also inspect and
that's very handy and if you work with
Jupiter notebooks
it's especially handy if you want to
explore data set you can iterate it
really explore a date and see what you
work with you can just pass in use the
head function just like in UNIX systems
on tail so hat will you get the first
five lines till the last ones and here
we're going to loop people we also have
an info method and what was the info
method gives gives us more insight and
we actually have in our data set so we
see here we have a name of a thousand
objects at a thousand entries in each
and every column and we see most of them
are objects but we already see units and
unit prices with integers and floats and
basically I just read in a text file and
pandas figured out the rest here which
is one of the great powers of man pandas
but probably something depending on the
data quality you're reading in something
you can also have to fight both pandas
or basically not fight with pandas use
canvas to fight who the data you're
reading in to get what you want so what
we can note here everything for example
let's go a little bit more up we have
obviously the birthday and the order
date this this is like a date and a time
stamp and if we just use the standard
methods here on the CSV files they still
store this object so it's not a
date/time object objects and canvas is
always like a string so they still store
the string so string date strings are
not that handy to really work with so
let's see what we can do about it so we
just use the same method and pass in one
more parameter which is actually pause
dates and in past dates we pass it pass
in the column names of the of the
date/time columns and the thing is
pandas will figure out the rest for us
so we have a new sales data open data
frame now and as you can see here the
birthday is now a day time and the order
date is not daytime so this is super
handy and and it's also highly
customizable so what we see here still
the same one carried something you have
to keep in mind
we did not into any instructions how our
dates are actually formatted so we can
do we can give instructions we can also
change the data later so we're going to
show you later but the date there's also
like auto positives included in pandas
and they're really good in guessing what
the best format is but they are not
perfect for every data set and for
example on the date time Plaza is a very
US state friendly and as you probably
know the u.s. is the only country in the
world which has month/day/year format
which is odd but it's friendly you can
be more explicit here in Paris you can
also pass and just like a first true so
they first true has as all we have dates
worth today at the very beginning and
this is also automatically armed for you
then but keep that in mind especially if
you have a data set which dates
beginning of the year it's or like with
lower date
they-they-they numbers it's it can be
really tricky and you end up with likely
crazy on dates
okay so we've read our first see if we
fall it's quite happy um what easy um
just let me I don't want to really go
into too deep into the methods but I
encourage you to read it by yourself for
example I think the read see is we
method has more than like forty
parameters you can pass into and this is
can be quite overwhelming for a beginner
because there's like isn't method for
everything
I'm not self I was quite happy to find
fun to find something I recently found
something there was no method building
in pandas it was very happy so just read
them through don't panic um stay focused
on the problem you want to solve and
also you don't
we need to solve all your problems on
importing the data already you can
mangle with your data
probably in a more flexible way later
and I'm going to show you a little bit
later how you can mangle and work with
your data once you have them in your
data frame so there are many methods arm
so and this is by the way a nice
application is called - and it's good to
store offline documents document in
documentation since I travel a lot this
is really handy if you want to look up
on the plane or like that so let's go
back so I'm Jason let's read in some
JSON and this is of course very simple
all the reached methods are very very
similar so um this looks just like quite
the same and let's see what we have here
again everything is imported as an
object but I'm a little confused because
like jason has a standard daytime format
I provides actually in standard a
platform still tenders tells me it's
still imported as an object and the
reason is in our sample data set on the
the take time format is not come it's
not a ISO arm it's not in the ISO format
so it's a little bit more free format so
Candice does nothing here so like so so
we have one approach really solve it arm
which leads us to the next input method
we can also just like read in the JSON
so this is our adjacent we see here we
we have an order date it look slightly
formatted but it's not as it's supposed
to be and Jason which is arm something
like this here arm you know like with
Athena mill so and of course we can do
all this cleanup and making it into a
date
our selves and of course we can also
change us use the JSON we read in then
we have a dictionary and now we changed
data and format in our dictionary so
this is just like um it pythonic on site
way we are taking here and of course we
can also read data just like from the
dig into Jason and this is what I'm
actually want to show you here so so we
have sales data from the dictionary in
Python so it's also pandas it's really
handy if you have data in Python and you
want to mangle it or export it to a CSV
file for example for example there is
also like the CSV library in Python um I
had to use it in earlier days nowadays I
only use pandas for it because it's much
more handy and powerful and simpler to
use now so we see here a birthday we
mangled we changed the day time we can
change the format to add a time in our
JSON so um this works correctly now but
num yeah this is basically yeah it's
just like one step what we did before
probably a little bit more proficient a
efficient here is to use the convert
States method where we can also a
parameter which we can just pass in
birthday in order date columns and
pandas does add the rest of the heavy
lifting here and let's look at our info
whether this was successful and yeah and
I encourage you if you read data and
really use this info method it's really
handy to see what's in your data set
like also um and we're going to explain
a little bit more later about why the
day type in pandas is important and it's
because it really pi Sinister's we don't
care about the types Python does most of
the stuff for us
so but in pandas it's it's one of the
things that brings all the performance
to pandas
so and we also help a described method
for our data frames and the described
method is more like basic statistics
about our data frames so we have account
we have like a thousand rooms where the
mean of the unique price and the units
we have a standard deviation the minimum
a maximum and the quartiles here so if
we want to take a peek into your data
it's really handy just reading the data
described method and you already have an
impression so what's in your data set
whether there are probably outliers on
there so if you have like s the maximum
is very far apart from and did the mean
yeah okay um here we go so and of course
um if you have to deal with sales
support or like classical industry like
they still love axial a lot and actually
I was never so fond of actual both
recently if I really fell in love with
it again because it's really handy
actually I am you will see in a bad so
we can also like work with axial guess
what you can read today the data just in
like by giving it a path to the excel
file but arm one nice thing here is you
can instruct which columns to pass so
and actually you know like all the
columns ABCD DD to wherever and then the
rows are just like numbered we can also
like just pass take the first two
columns so for example if we want to see
who the birthday the birthdays of the
people we have in our data set we can
just like immediately instruct pandas
only to get those two columns and into a
data frame and here that's the nice
thing about Excel data arm we see the
birthday it's already day time because
internally Excel supports day time it's
taught as an integer there so we don't
need to mangle any stuff here so arm
we're going to do X
working to Excel and exporting to see as
we dig and everything on I leave this up
to your imagination because it's
basically the same except for some
parameters you can constant so it's
really easy we just pass in a filename
um we have for example index false here
because we don't want the index export
in my excel file arm I just want to have
the columns here and we can also name
the sheet data and yep the actual is now
safe here on lady to imagination let's
save some time why did I recently fell
in love again with Excel when we were
building the European schedule so your
person has like 200 talks with like many
constraints people who speakers
availabilities topics should be grouped
in all this is a really hard problem
that's just like too many ways to solve
it so actually I built a piece of
software to do all the heavy lifting in
the schedule and then it was really hard
to I wanted something to visualize
everything so I started exporting all
schedules axle and this is just like a
picture as an example where Excel and
the close connection to pandas can be
really strong to use the XLS writer
library you can basically make this your
pandas excel excel writer you can even
like you can put colors um yeah like the
column sizes row hides everything here
and this was really handy because it was
very simple to set up
and before example we have the data
stuff which is red death lobsters like
lilac and so this was really handy to do
some useful simple report for the
program committee to decide this is a
good schedule or should we work on that
there's a little bit more so this is a
hint for if you to use if you work with
Excel and you really want to export my
excel sheets which makes your colleagues
from other departments happy look into
the XLS writer library there is a really
good arm documentation there with many
examples it's quite simple to do so um
let's go a little bit here and let me
just like so I just mark it and I just
copy it to my clipboard and this is also
something which can be really handy um
if you if you get structured data from
another source and you can just like
copy and paste it you can even just like
copy and paste it into pandas and of
course it does not always work that well
because it has to be not everything is
under summer let's give it a retry so
okay yeah so I copied these two lines
and I erected into the clipboard of
course
pandas pandas is just like checking
whether it's possible it will easily
break if there's just like half a column
missing or something like that of if the
rate of loss from word but for example
if you have it something like from SQL
queries or so it's super simple to get
it into your clip or if you want to just
like work it early so um that's already
the end of our first part of the like of
first session on getting into pandas
that's the end of our little light
warm-up so what we've learned reading
and writing data in pandas is really
simple um it's very customizable it's
very it can be overwhelming on to
beginners so don't be too overwhelmed
just like see concentrate on the problem
you want to solve and look for a right
parameter um to to solve it um a lot of
the handling is done really well by
pandas by default so you don't need to
configure a lot of the stuff on all this
very much depends on the data quality
you
basically not many times you have to
fight with the bad data quality you
probably have to work with and so
Antanas can be your friend so arm one of
the cabinets we haven't seen this here
because they're non null values in our
data sets um but something which is
sometimes we're confusing for beginners
if you read in a column with integers we
expect integers and they're imported as
a float it's because there are nine
values in there because only the float
data type can handle and values just
keep it in the back of your mind um and
yeah so yeah this is just like a little
summary any questions I think it's quite
easy peasy just warm up so you want to
do more stuff so where does all the
power come from pandas it's basically
that's why it's called over to num pi
because and pandas is built on numpy
numpy is in the miracles library r4 it's
the library for working with numbers in
python and that's why all the cow power
comes form if you know python python is
dynamically typed so you don't really
have to define types as another program
damages before and um so but of course
dynamic typing is taking performance
because what your code is running in the
background you always have to recheck
the type recheck the time what's
happening guessing and all the stuff and
so um num hi is typing the data so
they're going to see a little bit more
when we and i'll show you a little bit
more rotor data model um and also a
little bit more depth of definitions so
if we talk about a table tables often
refer to data frames um we have columns
and rows even like in with and pandas
and there's data series and data frames
and let's have a little bit more look
into the structure so our data is just
like an umpire array so this is just
like an array of integers for example
this is like a list but arm this is a
typed list and there's only one data
type in this list aloud so it's not like
in the Python this way you can have
strings integers whatever or mixed up in
your list so this is there's only one
data type on here and okay before we
cover this um so um we have our numpy
array here and a pandas series is
basically a labeled numpy array this is
just like one dimensional array so you
have the data and an index and for
example here the index is positional um
should actually start at 0 because we
have Seri indexing here as well and so I
when you work with punters is a little
bit it's very important what to think in
series and these series are like
verticals and because if you work with
data in a table you usually would rather
think in rows you iterate through each
and every row and of course there are
methods and pandas where you can
basically take your data frame and
iterate over the rows because it's
better for our hats but if you want to
get more creative and have a dieter and
that much more pleasant way to work with
pandas really try to think okay this is
a series and this is just like one
series and of course multiple series was
the same index this is a data frame so
basically the index is the link between
the series and it goes like everything
together to a data frame um there's also
another thing the three dimensional
object is called panel so if you stumble
across it you know oh I like told me
about it in Berlin but you can already
forget about it because it's been
deprecated because we can use multi
indexing for now for this so all we need
to do to remember here is one
dimensional data series and a data frame
is the two dimensional get one more
series or even one or more data frames
so from the definitions like like
synonyms we can say table is a to date
data frame on column is a data series a
row as the all the values at the same
position in each data series in the data
frame I would have loved to come up with
something more compact but that was my
best shot so um let's have a deeper look
into series every goods also say this
it's also in a notebook spot since I
have some added some extra stuff here
for visualization purposes and we're
going to use the slides here for the
tutorial so how do we create a data
series it's very simple arm because it's
called the series method PD series and
here we just pass in 10 random numbers
and this is our result and we see
already we already have a data type
because we asked for a random int from
random and positional index created on
the left side from 0 to mine so as 10
values there um very simple and how can
we access data in a series so we only
have a one dimensional we only have one
row now and how can we exit it we can
access it by position just like as we
can access this in Python so if we pass
in 0 we will get the first value and see
it is almost like the our series on the
right hand side so you can follow along
look easy we can also do slides as we do
with Python slices on from like 3 to 6
when we get this and there
also the I log method we can use and
please note square brackets now it's not
amalya choose square brackets for I lock
and we can do the same
so I lock is basically like integer
location so it can pass this in here so
um but as I told ya yes so lock code I'm
glad I'm going to cover it in just 10
seconds thank you yeah um so I thought
hold like you can imagine like a series
that we labeled it's labeled array arm
so let's set an index
I'm very well in indexes so we're just
resetting this to two letters so and now
we can still do the slicing on a series
here with the position like just like
the personick way we can even do slicing
with passing in labels now from D to F
so this panel super magic can I just
pass in any any slices no of course not
you can only slice the one block which
look is like if there's one value after
another so too many slices will fail we
can also contact for example if you want
to have like the rows d 2s and i2j the
best the better solution is to use the
concat method and pass in the two slices
here so we can you can get this here and
now I guess we come to the loc method
which was just asked about so of course
with the loc method we can now also pass
in a label and for example the label
here is in our case of string so the loc
method will look on the index the unlock
method will always go by the position so
and it's really easy to I log integer
unlock label and I integer location so
it's quite easy to remember
ah so the loc method does not its
support slicing but something is
different here we because I've set a new
index the index is no longer a 2j I
passed in Gattaca there a character XYZ
and I can use the loc method I cannot be
actually easy to get from G to A because
the index is not unique and as one of
the learnings of the pandas index panics
indexes are not necessarily in unique so
especially if you're just a second yeah
oh oh it's just you was just stretching
our okay okay yeah oh no g6 selects the
first G so the value 60 yeah yeah yeah
oh I'm sorry oh okay I have to fix the
slice I'm sorry look over there I'm
sorry oh thanks for finding that out
okay but here we have X Y Z are unique
in our values and here the loc method
will work so so this is can be a little
bit confusing for beginners especially
if you don't know about the index and
this is why I'm covering the indexes
this is a quite early stage because I
think it's it's one of the most
important things to understand and and
this is actually the index so actually
yes I know actually this is just like I
just take this is just like a list
comprehension taking each each letter
for renaming so it does not really
thought if I don't instruct a series to
sort explicitly so it's
yes actually like a it looks up in the
and here you see when the index is
unique it knows where to look and you
can see like it's there is there a match
so in between but it's not necessary I
think we could exchange the Y for
anything there yeah I get it now
it is the order in the index this is
useful to fly thing it's because it's
not it's not carrying about it's just
like an alphabetical label it just looks
for the label and until it hits the next
than the end of the slice so it's it's
it's still not intelligent so it's just
like it's just like iterating and see
what the slice can be so on the index so
actually like as I mentioned like the
label of the series is usually called
the index it's automatically created or
if you don't give it one you're
importing your data or create your
series as already saw it you can it can
be rien de stit can be replaced it's
immutable so you can just like decide oh
I have these duplicates here just like
go to the position and change one index
value um you have to reset the whole
index then it only can contain hashable
objects and so integers tuples strings
but of course not sets or dictionaries
it can have one or more dimensions so
tonight today we're only covering two up
to two dimensional now because we won't
have time and remember the convex index
is not necessarily unique so there's
multiple index types which I'm so sorry
we cannot cover them all
there's the index the multi index mostly
index is basically used for groupings a
lot there's a daytime index my favorite
index talk about it a lot let's dine
time Delta index and the new category
categorical index which was just
introduced into pandas with the latest
version and interval going to expert we
cannot cover them so it's let's go on
and see what how can we select data from
data frames so we have a data frame it's
out to dimensional data and we see we
have count data series is columns and
ten rows with some random integers and
let's see how we can slice them so we
can just access if we now pause use a
data frame and pass and just like an
integer we don't get the row we get the
column yeah this is very important
because as remember with the series we
got the value from the series which is
actually more like the row it's just
like a row with one value but so if you
select on data frame we select the
columns to series um we can also slice
but this is a very confusing if you
slice and put in like a range here we
get the rows back which is I think a
little bit logical break here which you
have to get used to on which can be felt
like can be confusing at the beginning
so we also have an I log method here and
the the I
not methods we can also like to take
select the segment probably you can't
see from the back is like four here I
use a mouse there's like mouse mouse
mouse okay yeah that's like four values
selected here arm and then we have to
pass in of course like two to four which
is actually like four zero axis and the
axis one and I'm going to explain you
and give you an how to remember both the
axis arm here little in a second so arm
we also have an eye lock method and the
eye loc method method um yeah basically
you kids also like the same also if you
want to use the aye loc method
um I ins the first is x0 is the Rose so
we pass them just like um for everything
like we can do in Python just like it's
arranged without start and end so
everything and the second to the fourth
column and this gives us picks back and
so I really have a lot of hard time at
the beginning to access zero access long
what's this so let me explain so
basically it's very simple X is zero is
the Rose so the horizontal axles one
other columns and since I'm one of these
guys who always like mixes of left and
right all the time
I found something to remember
so does this my what we call it is
Booker so the axis one looks like a one
because its vertical and this is like a
good way to remember oh yeah one gives
me back the series because it looks like
a one okay um next arm indexes are
indexes and column names are of course
when we created the data frame we only
had
just like positional values here of
course we can just like create it so I
magistrate resetting the index to some
sustar both are and have like two digits
same for the columns so we can just like
rename them really simple in pound us
the selection here is the same arm so we
can just like pass in Co five which will
give us back the label we can pass in a
range and remember ranges on data frames
go for the rows not the series and the
columns arm we can also use the range
here it works all the same logic we just
have look deeper with a Gattaca we can
also use the lock method on to get a
slice of in the middle of our data set
which is just like following the same
logic here arm and now we come to
something which we kind of call a
boolean indexing so and see yeah
sorry I yeah skip that booty in indexing
so what is this boolean index boolean
index has nothing to do with the indexes
I just mentioned um it's just like
called indexing as well so we see these
are the day this is the data we have in
our Co 4 series and we can create a
boolean index very easy if we just toss
in like get like the series greater than
60 and what we will get back is the
series with the same labels and the
values are just like true and false so
this is a boolean index boolean index is
just like an array of yes no yes no yes
yes yes here novo and basically if we
combine our data and the boolean index
we only get the data back where we hit a
yes so this is all the magic so if you
process the boolean index we have up
here and the outer square brackets on
we can just pass it in and it returns
back all the rows where our c4 is
greater than 60 and we can also do
combinations of this so we can pass in
an R just like with the pipe in the
middle note we have to put brackets
around the bullion indexers here at the
beginning like the arm smaller 60 and
greater 60 so this is just like we can
select anything else which is smaller
than 60 or greater 60 get back to rows
we can also do multiple ends and pass
them like anything which creates a
boolean index and this is one of the
things that the arm comes in with numpy
is the broadcast thing so if you work
with vectors you know like you can like
take one vector and multiply it with
another and this is like the same works
here so we can just like pass in okay
gives us back on the everything where
the mod of the value of mod 2 is 0 and
we only get these two rows in the end so
yeah to speed a little out because only
1/5 15 minutes left so yeah arm now
you're familiar with a data selection
and indexing on data series and data
frames please keep in mind the selection
one data series and data frames the
slicing is different this can be a
little bit confusing at the beginning
because you're probably not always aware
we're really working on a series or a
data frame in the very beginning also
when you select data
you always get a copy of the data return
so and most of like all the operations
you do on data frames are not applied to
the data frame until you explicitly
instruct so we will see that in a minute
because when we come to operations so
operations I want to show you how can we
add and remove C
um do stuff like adding subtracting
mangling the data and how can we be
working with null values with your nm so
let's go to the next here okay yes yes
you're right oh I'm very relieved now
you're right thank you probably should
have thought my water oh yeah oh yeah we
have 42 minutes left oh okay let's do
some exercises now so okay I am well
since we have 40 minutes left
thank you again questions on selecting
indexing or anything else now
yeah the columns are it some time ago
okay yes the question is how do can we
index row columns so I actually columns
are not indexed columns have names but
we can just let me go back a bit me show
you here here on that top here we reset
the index and we set the column names
just like like passing and a list of the
names you want to has there
oh the boolean indexing you mean like
boolean indexing for columns not a
really good question ah but but but yeah
this is
yeah yeah but how can you how I think
you basically the work with series how
because like then it's Road so basically
you have transposing it's probably the
best thing or just like get the series
because like I am yy-you transpose the
column like they know my why do you want
a boolean index for the column what's
like the use case you think oh um you
can you can also like select a column
just like by the names if you want to
okay yeah okay yes you can just like
select one or multiple columns just like
by passing in a list of the column names
oh yeah so you don't need to boolean in
the exodus if you want to use boolean
indexing for columns you could just do a
list of your columns and two boolean
indexing on this one then you could then
you could give the list to your premise
data for him then you get boolean
indexing for columns yeah
for example yeah so actually I've never
stumbled to crying about any actually so
but thanks for bringing it up yeah um I
just wanted to ask if I select one
column yeah is it automatically a series
yes so I don't need to convert it to a
series no no if you if you select the
column you get back a series also
including the labels so the index so the
holding index comes always back it was
in the background so all right cool so
we're worried so it's um okay so what
can we do to mango with our data how can
we work a little bit more in the series
that's what I just like sum it up with
operations um so let's get our favorite
data set back and remembering here arm
storage in the DF for a def data frame
so um we can also like where dynamically
with our data frames so we can add
columns delete columns select rows so
for example like if you for example just
select a part of our data frame you
always get back a new data frame or
series if you only want to select one
series and you can work with that data
frame or series as well any other series
you created so basically if you have
like a huge data frame it's very easy to
go to all use pandas just like to take
two slides out the part of the data
frame and work with it and without
changing anything else um so um
let's just like add another 11 column
called 310 to our data frame that's
simple
so the roots as you see this was just
like a list our width of the sill the
same size like ten numbers we added to
our data frame so as I just like
explained it's really easy to take a
series out is it also this that is it
just like to recreate a new series and
pass it in so let's see so what we going
to do here so here we create a new
series of the pandas series and by
passing the same list with like ten
integer values here and now we have a
new series so let's let's have a look so
this is our new series and let's just
like add this new series to our data
frame oh why did the stupid Python list
work and our super sophisticated pandas
will not work ideas index thank you yes
of course because when you add data and
this is if you add series to data frame
pandas is actually looking at the index
and since
we have like these are zero to our nine
labels on our index here our new series
had just like an auto index which was
just like positional index from zero to
nine so of course this not did not work
so if I want to add a series to my data
frame I have to basically just like do
an index here and this is what I want
just like let's make it an extra step
so here we create a new series and it's
really easy to just like get the index
from our data frame and set it as the
index of our new series that's very
simple of course this has to have the
same length
um and so of course this is really easy
um to set you could also for example you
can also add we are not going to cover
joints here but for example if you have
like a smaller your critics also have
used like a series with like only six
values for example from just like R 0 0
to R 0 5 and add these to our data frame
so it's not necessarily they have the
same length of course pandas would then
add na n values just put like we saw
here so we would have like 6 3 values
here from whole list and the rest would
be automatically null values so this is
really easy and handy if you have to
join data from various sources if you
have labels corresponding labels it's
super easy to get everything together in
one data frame so let's add this as
another one has 12 on here how can I get
rid of it arm so I want to have my data
playing frame small a little bit more
readable so there are many ways to do
this one is just to use del like in
Python delay and then just like remove
the series from our data frame arm
so just remember here we go up to 10
what a capital of course if I pass in a
column name unknown I will get able to
get a quiero
but if we're not sure about whether we
have columns in our data frame we can
also avoid key arrows if we use the drop
method
and just like instructed to ignore
errors so we can just like drop any
column by name with the drop method
without raising errors if the column is
not present that's really handy if you
get data from outside and there's
different column names there um of
course if you want to have like just
like a smaller selection if you just are
if you're just like interested in like
for example like two rows of your data
frame there's no need to delete all the
others you can basically just like
create a new data frame on with the lock
method and just like instructed give me
give us back all the rows here and just
like these two columns and just like
store it to a new data frame or
overwrite the data frame a variable
you're working of already so this is
very easy um so and how can we mangle
the data we have in our data frames so
let's do a little recall on numpy
broadcasting arm and what that is
basically so we just create one array a
on here with like three values and
another one be also free values and
broadcasting is this is pretty simple
simple so we have these two rays three
values each and if we want to we just
can for example just add them to another
so and of course like the values are
added according to their opposition we
can subtract them we can multiply them
we can divide them we can even like just
like add a constant to it so arm since
there's only one value seven will be
added to each and every value this is
just like broadcasting and
we can also divide it by full integer
here so this is all 0 so and of course
we can also just like multiplied by
another array so yeah this is the idea
of broadcasting I think everybody got
the idea and the same works comes at
hand if you work with pandas series so
imagine you have series and there's like
multiple values and there's often stuff
you want to do on with these values so
let's get back to our sales list the
sales is from the Bluth store so this is
just like some customer data arm so we
have a customer the customer as a
company we know the first name of the
person who purchased it um we know their
birthday arm
we have an order date um if a product
name these are like the 10 most
successful products of all times arm
according to some internet list with the
unit price which we the price we asked
when the item was sold and how many
units the customer ordered and this is
just like random data and let's see so
for example what what we are missing
here for example management asked us
okay what what was turnover we say okay
yeah we have a unit price and a unit but
we really miss the turnover data so
let's add a new series called turnover
to whole data frame so cuz all dataframe
we add a new series we label it turnover
and it just can pass in the two series
unit price and the price which we
actually asked arm and just like
multiply them it's as simple as that and
now we know have another series in our
data frame for turnover and now we can
also ask more information for example
what's the mean what there are mean
turnover our or for example probably
even more interesting so we see we have
all these nice methods we can actually
all apply them directly on oh sorry
let's copy this ah it can we can also
just like easily get the sum of our
turnover of our data set here um so then
it can also just ask what's our medium
turnover and and of course um we can
also have a closer look at our data in
what the info method so for example arm
we can also work with the data we have
in our series in a very flexible way
with for example the map methods so a
map method here is just like in any
other programming language and
mathematic is map this and take each and
every value of a list and apply a
certain function to it on method that's
a map so what are we doing here we want
to know get create a new our column just
like what 1/8 the year or the purchase
was made so we take the order date we
know here the order date is already a
date time of object so we don't need to
do any data conversions here and we can
pass in a lumped up function so all we
do here is take each and every value
daytime object and just like ask for the
year of the data object and we can just
access it directly with dot here and
python and this is what we get so we
have the year now the same we can do
just like for a month and
in case we are interested in getting
some easy report for year and month for
example to do a plot or report or
summary we can also combine multiple
columns so we here we're creating a new
year month column and we can just pass
in the two series and basically I'll
concatenate them with just like by
adding one to another arm one thing here
the year is of course we cannot just
like a Python won't allow us to take an
integer and add another integer to two
and because we were looking for string
so what we do here we take the data from
the year pause and map just like string
so each and every value in this series
will be converted to string there are
other methods to do this we will see in
a second and of course we want to have
like two digit month they are nicely
formatted and it's as simple as this and
now we have our year most column one
hint if I wanted to create a sales
report on your monthly basis both data
like that I would not do it like this
it's really it's good to do it
if your due to pandas if you want to
have your data really visible but this
would be a super cool case for the
daytime index which we won't cover here
today just like as a hint
yes the difference is that oh yeah sorry
thank you what's the difference between
map apply map and apply map actually
basically just was about to explain here
later map is for series I play you apply
you can work on a data frame with that
and apply map is basically you can apply
it to the whole data frame but as far as
I know there is no
big difference anymore between apply and
apply map it was only in the beginning
because if it I think if we do this here
we will get the same result so as we see
we this was just basically a slide for
the whole data frame and if we only use
apply we get the same I'm not wondering
percent sure it was on I think it was
only a difference in the early days I
think it was merged into arm so yeah as
we see arm we can also apply along to
functions to a data frame so we can just
like get a subset of our data frame just
like two columns and apply anything to
them for example will be by 10 by 1.5 or
whatever we want to do so but as you see
here um this is because like very often
forgotten in the beginning here we have
sales data we select you we apply
something we get like new values back
but if we look at our data frame
nothing has changed this it's really
important to know that handles always
returns a copy of the data and it does
not apply all this directly on the data
frame unless you instruct it to do so
with the emphasized methods so you
cannot put say do something to a series
pass in in place true and then the data
frame will change otherwise you can also
just like reassigned a variable arm for
this in for your data frame that's the
same yes
actually like that's that's another
thing which is very overwhelming there's
not only one right way to do it there
are many ways to do the same in panda so
it's basically it depends on you yeah I
probably actually have never worked that
much in introduction oh okay thank you
as far okay why it's broadcasting faster
than applying a method so and actually
honestly I have never measured because
most of the times are not really worried
about like getting the most of the
performance because pandas tandas claims
itself it's good for handling data up to
one gigabyte in memory so and I am a
bigger dataset in memory without really
having any troubles hooded camels always
is fast and I probably I say I used to
worry about performance at the beginning
ah a lot in the early days and nowadays
I just say I only worry about if I have
a performance problem so and there are
methods to use for like bigger data sets
but we won't cover it in an introduction
here but there's some nice thing from
Tom ox burger is some nice tutorial how
to work with bigger data sets of stats
and I think he's also like that there's
also an explanation upon the performance
differences mm-hmm I have another
question
the other functions to perform
computations in place directly without
copying in the game are there functions
to perform the computations in in place
without a and you can you can pass them
in place and then the data frame will
change yeah so that that that's
important so usually if you take some
data out of Panda
do something with it you always have a
copy but you can also instruct it with
in place true entice a equals true to
apply directly to the data frame um yeah
so uh here um we also have a describe
method on our whole data frame so we can
see the same cecile data we saw for
earlier for the series with like count
means standard deviations minimum
maximum here and of course this works
also series still so for example also
for like a daytime series so we see we
have 284 unique birthdays within our
thousand people we have here and the
most popular is the most popular
birthday that's the top birthday
so what else um so for example we have
now floats in our turnover we can also
easily change the type of a series in
pandas we can just pass so we if we want
to replace it here we pass it into our B
this is like the replacement here we
sign the new turnover our will we get
back from math type and I want to okay
thank you um so I can just like say okay
make this like an integer like with
Empire numpy integer or just like
passing int and this will return the
float value as integer and we just save
it back to the data frame and one thing
is especially if you get data from the
outside and/or which is not like clean
or not a z1 so let's sneak in some null
values arm so as we see we have known
null values in our dataset for unit
price
and also for yeah for the order date so
this is model timestamp then so on you
can check your data frame um if there
are any novel is there because sometimes
if you pass in like a more special
function this might lead to an exception
and we don't want that so it's null
gives us back any row where we have a
null value we can also just like drop
the null values from all data frame so
we see we've lost some lines here but
remember this is also the drop and a
method returns a new data frame so this
would be a super good place oh yeah I'm
showing here yeah in a second so yeah
this is just like a copy from the data
frame so nothing has changed on the same
is for we can also pass them with fill
and a default values um if we want to if
we know okay better guess the data will
have this zero there some like that you
can also be like more sophisticated
fills forward fills we won't cover it
here so you can even like write your own
interpolations for this it's necessary
but as we see our data frame has not
changed so this is again an example for
the in-place method so here we do fill
RNA will for 99.99 and for every no
value we had in place true and as we see
now actually our data frame has changed
and every null value is replaced and as
you can see here also the na T values
will be replaced by this so there's no
difference now so because this was na t
to say that na Nana na tv4 and so we
know like in the 70s here very early
order so okay to sum this up off
[Music]
you see how you can apply map mangle
your data working with ni n and all the
stuff na and n isn't representation of
null values you can rehab the place them
drop the lines it very much depends on
the data set you work and you need how
you want to handle null values sometimes
you can drop them sometimes you need
some default values here so and
modifying data series and data frames
arm is very important to know it always
gets returned to copy and of course I'm
emphasizing it a lot yeah because it's
often forgotten and with a parameter in
place the result can be applied directly
to the data frame we are working with so
where we are Here I am
okay anymore introduction Airy questions
on this in the filling in emitter is it
possible to write some conditions such
as if the turnover is less than 500,000
fill the null values with this number or
silicon writer you can write a Python
method as you wish and just passes it
past them so we need to include this
villainy inside those if conditions are
use condition not like I was asking
something like fill any inside the
proper way mmm I'm actually I'm not sure
whether the fill and a will do this arm
probably will are I think so now I
actually have to look it up
documentation whether it's but it should
accept the method as well okay if not
you can also do a map on the series and
there you can definitely pass in any
custom functions you want no and if you
hit an own
value can also check to meant the value
of is it's an and value and then apply
whatever you want in a very custom
fashion okay alright then
then as the last part that's just like a
sneak peek into visualization and
grouping so pandas always comes built in
what were there many Wizards simple with
the realization tools and it's also very
easy to customize them that's all
handled by map load lip and there's also
like many libraries involved on so here
for example this is just like
instruction to plot within our Jupiter
notebooks if you haven't seen it before
so we read in our sales data
um again calculate out some turnover
here and now we do grouping we want to
visualize a little bit a sales report so
let's do a group boy which is a very
simple aggregation you probably if you
know SQL or self it's it's the same so
we just take one key which is the
product name here and we want to group
and group it by the product and
basically get the song back and let's
just have a look and here um yeah that's
basically it so important here we here
we do a selection of the columns we want
to work with it's just like a product
and to turn over the group boy are is
done by the product this group I will
only accept of course columns which are
selected so we could also take the whole
data frame you so
is not absolutely necessary but for
example we would not really interested
to get the sum of the unit price here
that's why I'm doing a pre selection
because the some of the unique prices
quite pointless so so and then we stir
it into the TT um variable here and then
it's really easy then we can just like
take our take this and just do a ball
plot and we can just like put take the
data frame or the theory or series plot
it and at the bar for bar or we can su
can do the same for the mean or sophie
or the unit soul-stirring uh so this is
a new grouping about like the how many
units are sold which is a little bit
more nicer to plot so we can use it have
it as a bar plot the nice thing here is
of course we also have more plots
building or format learn what what a
nice thing is you can still work with
these plots so it's not just like take
this plotted and that's it so the plot
returns the ax object from matplotlib so
and you basically that's the plot object
and you can still work with it and
improve it for example here I was
interested in okay what's the what's the
median of the medium of the unit sold
which is quite obvious here so here we
can just like take the ax object we get
back so I'll save it in a variable
called X as well and just and use less
you horizontal line here with a method
from McLaughlin's directly and here
which is
the unit we have just aggregated or take
the medium of them arm to find a color
and align style and just like
immediately added to the same plot and
another nice thing here it just looks
too simple all the labels from your
index and the data you work with are
automatically added to your plots as
well so it's really handy because in
earlier days all this plotting was a lot
you had to do sometimes a lot of
customization on it to have a nice cloth
is understandable for outsiders and not
familiar with the data set so here
pandas does all the heavy lifting for
you as well okay let's just like see a
little bit more about what we can plot
or aggregate for example um this is just
like not so useful top so by default we
get a line clock back and also if I
group by each and every day order date
which is the time step actually it's not
very readable so if there's something
you can do about it and finally I get
about a bigot it gets a little bit more
to talk about how Andy for example the
time series index can be armed so we
here have our sales data and we reset
the index now to reorder date the order
date is a date time X yeah sorry um
could you please thank you is the order
date is already a timestamp the day time
object and so we set our index now to
these day x objects and this creates my
most beloved data time index and so this
is what it looks like now here so we
have some positional values here in the
beginning arm and now with the data
option and now we can do something
really nice we can take our sales data
group it by the sales data index year
and week for example so the day time
index
has is directly you can directly access
on the data year day mum quarters you
think about it it's like a list like
this queue and so here we go pry and
next year the Mogu Basu and and a week
we want to look into the week take the
sum and just like plot it and this is
basically all for each and every week we
get this plot back you can also use
other libraries for example like bulky
or Seaborn
Alfred matplotlib is very you can
customize the MATLAB lib really easy as
I just demonstrated a lot of probably
like a seaborne or pokey are more
suitable if you want to have interactive
visualizations but that's probably
enough for a tutorial itself and and
this is like the last example um for
example here for grouping and
immediately plotting the data our with
my plot lip is just like we can also
just like see house basically like the
distribution of our sales across
weekdays and we even can group by them
with our daytime index here and plot it
to a pie and I would say arm just have a
look at the documentation to see all
those articles per we have to get ready
okay
tutorial yeah alright so yeah that's
awful
I was at the end anyway so thank you
very much
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah time for questions now but I'm sure
the speaker will be available
yes idolater in the come feel free to
ping me or talk to me thank you